non
je prends des coups ça c'est sûr mais
votre matière c'est nouveau je crois que
les comptes soient au rattrapage
non je crois pas allez bon courage allez
hop hop hop
à chacun son tour légalement en fait on
a construit un c'est bien ça c'est
important le soutien ouais il va en
avoir besoin votre pote bon c'est quoi
ton nom déjà d'un moulin à le bon ça va
tu as que 42 points attrapé rien
d'insurmontable ça va tu à 8.8 de
moyenne en plus c'est bien ça symétrique
et oussama ben voilà c'est ça c'est
symétrique ouais bien sûr tu as eu cinq
en anglais 4 ans shiloh 4 ans shiloh 5
ans c'était quoi le sujet pointu sur le
choix l'animal en haut tu vas aller
serrer pour ton pote moi c'est un truc
sur le choix d'un libertin d'accord et
ce huit ans d'histoire c'est quoi en
licence et ce baiser paraffine falloir
s'habituer
ok bon tu vas prendre philo est anglais
je voulais plutôt prendre échos le court
c'est vrai que tu as eu que neuf en écho
à temps je t'explique pourquoi philo
c'est mieux est ce que tu penses que
c'est en philo c'est dans ses cordes où
on peut quand même je crois
voilà donc ce site à 7 tu peux avoir 8
ans est d'accord sita 8 tu peux avoir
neuf je crois ouais et site à neuf il ya
quel raison que t'es pas 10 je ne sais
pas non il n'a pas de nom et citadis
qu'est ce qui empêche côté 11e c'est
qu'on met au point un nouveau truc dans
skype en vain et bah ouais il peut avoir
20 ouais c'est exactement ce que je
voulais entendre parce que guillaume il
va se retirer doigts du cul et il va
bosser tout le week-end
un guillaume d'accord ok bon on y croit
les gars là on est à fond on a très bien
à la convocation
[Musique]